I had a quick question related I guess
to the middle of scandal and and about
investments what what is the role of of
investments for financial investments
for foundations but more generally how
does sustainability of a foundation how
does that play into the elie wiesel
foundation I think specifically for
Louise L foundation or variety of others
I almost feel like I'd like the need for
foundations and NGOs to be wiped off the
face of the earth if there were equality
fairness access to resources health
there might be less need so in terms of
the roll toward perpetuity perpetuation
I think foundations and good-hearted
people should exist and keep struggling
until the problems the wrongs were
trying to write go away and nothing
gives me more pleasure than to see a
foundation solve a problem close its
doors and move on to do other good work
or have the individuals move on to do
other good work what do you think right
I mean the reason why i was asking was
because a previous guests had told us
that she has a time limit to her
organization and that it is going to
last for 20 years and about close the
doors after that and pass on the work of
that organization which is to promote
school schools in in guatemala and to
the local people and that kind of thing
and I guess I was just curious I see a
lot of foundations which are focused on
sustainability for for perpetuity and I
I was trying to it I think to think
through that or so I've actually really
curious to hear what you think but my
feeling is it needs to be focused a
foundation should be focused on what
we're trying to achieve if its
eradication of smallpox and we're able
to eliminate that disease and then close
the doors so be it if it's righting
social wrongs but to me there's a
difference between private foundations
in
dividual donors groups of donors and
public charities I think that an
individual after paying taxes and
whatever is required you should be able
to spend the resources in a responsible
way but if it's your money you can
choose whether you'd like 20 years 1
year or try to set something up in
perpetuity that's your right to me I'd
be less my suggestion or what I
constantly questioned myself is I don't
care about the money the foundation /
are we solving the problem do we have
the right stakeholders at the table and
what did you what was your reaction when
you heard that really enough 20 years
yeah I mean I guess it was my first
instinct was was similar that I guess
the time limit wasn't what was
interesting to me but whether the the
goal would be achieved and I guess I was
curious also if maybe the goal isn't
achieved through the methods of the
foundation or the charitable work maybe
there's another method that should be
approached and I think you're writing to
me that one of the questions is if the
model of a foundation is a donor or
group of donors dispersing resources a
model if the model of a foundation is
doing good and achieving measurable
outcomes sometimes that's a different
model I'm much more a fan of trying to
measure what we're trying to achieve to
make sure we have an inclusive feedback
loop so that it's not a question of a
donor deciding what's best for this poor
person or this person in need I'd rather
people tell me what they need or tell us
what they need and then we can team team
up to try to solve it